[Music]
uh this happened a while ago but you
know there's a lawsuit that comes from
it so we're talking about it now there
was a family who was kicked off of a
flight after passengers complained that
they smelled the whole family I would
like to know this whole story now go
ahead and uh go ahead and guess the
ethnic group that this family is Bart if
I were to be racist Anthony I would say
Indian that's [__] I also said Indian I
only if I'm being racist Anthony first
of all I love Indian people okay so calm
down bar second of all they're not
Indian what's your second guess racist
yeah no it's being racist
Anthony white trash on the record
incorrect my white my white trash people
are you is he white trash yeah are you
kidding me goddamn patron saint is Jesus
Christ Christian what's wrong with you
I'll tell you who they're not I'll tell
you who they're not they're not Mexican
cuz they have the best smelling laundry
in the world smell like detergent like
crazy never metad there's a difference
between they have the best laundry in
the world they smell like detergent no
sorry softener okay yeah not detergent
my bad their [__] smells but either way
we'll take it dude okay well this couple
was kicked off of flight over claims
that they had quote bad body odor and
they filed a federal lawsuit against
Nick's favorite Airline American
Airlines American Airlines claiming they
were victims of religious and racial
discrimination religious why religious
cuz it's their religion a
stank exactly it says it are they rostas
and they smell like weed
do and they were just like I don't
understand the skunk smell wasn't
expecting that at all I'm like yo pass
the weed dude that smells good dude what
a wild card they were not Rosas this is
it maybe not the best picture but this
is a picture of the family that was
kicked off I don't want to continue the
story they're I can't tell what what are
they doing they're being kicked off
they're Jewish they're off that's
Jewish god Dam right how you feel about
that are they your people look but
Jewish people aren't known for smelly
food I don't know if was the food man oh
like smelly skin some [__] I'd also like
to know the whole story here guys like
somebody's like hey we got to like
remove from flight like why and they got
violent you know what I mean I'll just
say one they got a little
caddy forget comparing the races that
always goes bad yeah within a single
given
race you got your great racial
stereotypes and you got your bad ones
stereotypes are statistically a little
bit of Truth to them at least am I right
yeah yeah that's why they're stereotypes
yeah but there's no stereotype of stinky
Jewish I've never heard of that I've
made many jokes okay made many jokes
anything hateful I can attach to the
Jewish people I just go doesn't even
have to make
sense but you know some of us are at
various places on that intra racial
hierarchy and and some people are like
Dam like you're really repping that [__]
you know what what's that guy's name
that played in the NBA uh one of you
people Jeremy lyy L Jeremy
ly you [__] said it too that's true when
a Japanese businessman buys a dirty
underwear from a vending machine I go
why is it got to be another one of us to
do that or we went fishing one time and
there was a Japanese guy in the boat and
guess what he caught all the fish he
caught the biggest but that's a good
stereotype but all the fish have
radiation or when when white girls go to
and get PS all's you're like then we
made it even worse Asia stereotype we
robbed that
[__] took his Bish we from
America but yeah some of the people in
any
race just kind of are having a bad time
with things some of them might even have
a profound amount of terrible body odor
that they're exuding hey can they sue us
for a comedy podcast uh they can sue
them if anything [__] you guys my name's
Anthony Lee we'll be in trouble I own
barbell Brigade all right so this is
that's a very good disclaimer by the way
why do you look like that according to
Yosi Adler and his wife okay they were
the uh in the civil action this couple
Yehuda ysf Adler and Jenny Adler told
how they suffered from quote unbearable
humiliation embarrassment and mental and
emotional anguish they got great you
lawyer to [__] make that up
unbearable [__] you still look
like you around you look like you bar oh
there a pause pause I'll Riff on this
[__] [__]
we made it through [__] generations
of [__] oppression Holocaust shrug
that [__] off and then you get [__]
someone tells you smell it or play like
oh it's
unbearable my pancreas you guys know the
[__] motto for the IDF the Israeli
Defense Forces one of the best
militaries on the planet is never again
that's the [__] model again again and
you're and they're out to [__]
Israeli Navy Seals kill everybody Israel
assassinates other [__] people it's
the only state to take credit for
assassinations and then you're out here
[__] morah high whatever the [__]
like I I was embarrassed on a plane damn
it n up goddamn great race out here what
are you doing there's other people
you're
[Laughter]
represent what a t sometimes we see punk
ass Asians do punk ass [__] [__] like
God damn it why are we the same are
watching the rest of us true and they're
judging us they like why you got to be a
stereotype Dude entirely wrong you say
Kanye yeah I'm not going to say the
other guy
yeah he wasn't entirely wrong yeah yeah
he's had a few good points
here but uh yeah it's just you know what
else did he say yeah so the staff at
Miami International Airport removed them
and their 19-month-old baby daughter off
the plane they said they couldn't return
du allegations okay she
smells on the flight but to be honest
like they stinky all of a sudden as soon
as they took us off they closed the gate
and then they said sorry sir some people
complained you had bad body water and
were not letting you back on
his wife claims they were so confused
about the whole thing they stopped
people in the airport to find out
whether they did in fact smell that's
weird this whole story getting they do
do you think they ask excuse me can you
smell me really quick smell like this is
[__] no no be honest yes yes you
smell like [__]
[__] and then they're like oh no dude
it's weird has an heir look good that
that quote there's no [__] there's no
[__] [__] way that happened but
also apparently some of it did There's
you as like a [__] whoever it is like
that owns cuz like an Airlines like
there's somebody that's like the gate if
that's their job like you gate 10 for
this flight you're in charge like the
head whatever the [__] to be able to be
the person that has to make that call
cuz the pilot hits you up like the
[__] suie come back over here she's
like there's a problem with the door
like Su get over here those people have
to get off they smell and you're like
you're just a mild mannered [__]
Latina woman who lives in Miami and
those are [__] job every day and
they're like go tell those three Jewish
people they can't be on here anymore cuz
they smell like [__] and you're like
Jesus Christ just do this with [__]
tickets I scam people's phones I'm nice
to people who yell at me I don't I'm not
built for this but then they're like do
your [__] job that's tough you off
you smell you smell you smell you're
cool you
smell that's why I got to lie to him
they got to bait them off they got to be
like oh there's a problem there's an
issue we need drop the plane real quick
there someone with your ticket Clos the
door and then they like actually smell
yeah you know what do you think they got
your stereotypes go they're celebrating
Hanukkah early they're like hi uh free
mat a hot place they were sweating Miami
is very warm yeah it's humid you know
what would get me off the flight like
sir I don't mean to disturb you you seem
already very comfortable but there is a
person who is in net worth in the
billions giving extensive detailed stock
portfolio management advice just outside
the the complicated [__] bait ever
just outside the gate just
outside and he's got nobody to hear his
advice he's actually writing notes for
you he's giv power points and I'm like I
honey we got I got I got to hear this
guy out and then boom they close the
door I don't even give a [__] I'm like
hey [__] that plane I'm I'm hearing my
man even though your wife's still on the
plane she's good she can take care so
fun mean ass Filipina [__] she's good
I'm more worried about other the other
people on the flight having to deal with
her you know people get worried about
their wives and [__] like oh you know CU
she like she travels for it she's a
super famous like uh She's Like A Team
USA doctor for Olympics and [__] like
that and she'll like fly all around the
world like I don't know what she does
like fix athletes when they fall off
their various sporting equipment and uh
you know people say like oh my wife's
going XYZ country like I'm worried about
her I'm never I'm worried she's going to
start a [__] international incident
the Slovenian Army has like a problem
they to call Nato like what's going on
like we can't stop this one person she's
destroyed three tanks ey lasers coming
out what do we do must be very proud so
proud so proud she worries about you
yeah exactly sounds like that's true
really it's more like hate of not
worry I I do have a Chinese Asian woman
impression but this is too
political I think now's the right time
you know I think this is the right place
to do
it Place Jerry if this gets us cancelled
what are we going to do for
work we're going to work at a Chinese
restaurant I'm going to order I would
like chicken broccoli please so the way
you start I started curating this
impression a long time it's going to
suck it's going to suck I don't think so
but it's pretty choice so people with
their Impressions they try to talk too
much like they would and understand a
lot of [__] that comes out of cuz I'm
foreign I'm from Russia myself so I have
great Russian impression that's too easy
but like foreigners don't say the [__]
you think you're going to say so when a
an old ass Hong Kong talk this is a very
specific impr canones even better 98
years old cigarette and M has run some
combination of incredible Chinese
restaurants and whouses her entire life
and she's looked 98 for the last I don't
know a thousand years before that she
was beautiful the most beautiful and
she's so [__] resentful that she
doesn't look like that she sells these
[__] way way harder she has no love
for them at all you know who I'm talking
about I do your grandma or
thank and and then so it's the landlord
from Kung Fu Hustle it is with the
slipper yo that's a real [__] person
that's time I know 880 people like
there's a [__] amazing your due
diligence 100% Chinese restaurant in
metro Detroit with this lady's [__]
real and I just copied her and I got
this impression and so she first of all
her tone of voice was always yelling at
you that's you want to order something
she was start and you were like what the
[__] is
that what you want all that and you're
like hello she's like wow what you want
to order and you're like oh what do I
want to order I've seen her yell down
like 6'4 300 lb black men and they're
just
like whatever you say she [__] pure
ener and I don't she seems to [__]
hate everyone around her one time I was
like I had come back to restaurant like
20 years later I was there as a kid and
I was like oh like it's great to see you
she like oh yeah she can't tell us apart
I know that and and then so she's like
I'm like oh do you like do you own the
restaurant she's
like I made a punchline [__] why is it
hilarious you've been here for 95 years
I ass soon just own the place he was
like a that's ridiculous yeah ridiculous
ridiculous there's 18 Silvers in there
she's not trying to say that's bad for
you yeah so oh [__] that's very
good plenty more of that cosigned by
asan you're doing Russian in the next
video